thanks for being here so I'm glad to be
here to talk about designing very
progressive web apps so I want to start
by asking you a question
why doesn't the web feel good have you
noticed that you when you're scrolling
through out a mobile website the
experience is not as perfect as a native
app so there are lots of mobile web
problems that are happening the average
load on a mobile website is around 19
seconds that's a lot if you're scrolling
on mobile web all day and if you notice
that sometimes the scrolling is very
slow or it lags so there are lots of
unresponsive situations on mobile web
sometimes the content jumps when you're
scrolling through out a website which is
really frustrating is a frustrating
experience sometimes when you're
browsing a website on mobile you tap on
an image by mistake then it closed the
next page and then you have to wait
another 19 seconds to load notice for
you to come back to the previous page so
the user doesn't really feel in control
when they are browsing a mobile website
so I'm here to tell you that the web can
feel good and not just good but great
with progressive web apps I always
wanted to use this effect so let me
start by introducing myself I Michal
and I'm a UI x designer and i'm also a
design teacher at lo hago which is the
coding bootcamp that teaches web
development in nine weeks so let me
refresh your memories a bit if you don't
know this already
what makes an app a PWA so first a PWA
is fast it loads quickly performed
smoothly
that's because of service workers and
the best practices for performance a
progressive web app is progressive it's
supercharged in modern browsers which
means it works anywhere everywhere and
you can enhance the experience for
devices that support more advanced
features
hence the term progressive enhancement a
professor robot is connectivity
independence that's one of the most
important features of a progressive web
app it works offline and it works with
low end connections so no matter what
the internet is it should work perfectly
a progressive web app is engaging users
are more likely to use a PWA rather than
a mobile website due to the fact that
you could install it to the home screen
and have push notifications which
increases the conversions and it even
increases engagement and there are lots
of companies and big brands that are
using progressive web apps five miles
shoppers spend 20% more time browsing
through products than they did on the
previous site The Weather Channel saw an
80 percent improvement and the load time
after shipping pwace and there are lots
and lots of more companies that had
create conversions and engagements was
there for the earth pwace can find more
staff on pwace dot-com
so now the real question is how can we
design create progressive web apps let's
divide the most three most important
features of the PWA a PWA is applied it
should feel like a native app that is
local on your phone the PWA is engaging
it should be responsive with the users
input and very fast and a PWA is
resilient it's reliable it works
perfectly with any internet connection
so throughout this talk I'm going to do
some UX and technical recommendations to
make great progressive web apps I start
by the first section how can we have a
more earth-like experience your PWA
should meet the users expectations as if
it's a native app so the design should
be like a native app and the common
mistake for designers or front-end
developers is the design web like
components for gwas as if it's like a
normal website so the first thing we
need to do
it's takes on the ex inspiration from
native apps so in order to match the
users mental model of a net of a native
app we need to design more earth-like
components for our PWA so we can do that
by browsing sites like patterns calm or
dribble calm and get inspired from
sections that are related to native apps
so patterns Assam is a place where you
could get inspired from mobile design
patterns you could choose Android iOS or
more and you could browse some
components and it's also divided into
categories another thing we can do is
level up our familiarity with material
design because users expect the design
and interaction and everything around
your PWA
to be engaging and functioning like like
a native app so familiarize yourself
with material design principles things
like the interactions generations the
colors and everything around the
principles of material design you could
do that on materials at i/o what you can
do also is use material design
components MVC is a framework by Google
which is modular and customizable UI
components and the nice thing about MVC
is that it's modular which means you
could choose the components you want to
use and use them only you don't have to
download the whole framework so some
components are like ripples little
animations cards colors grids everything
around material design
remember that your app will sit next to
the other native apps on your home
screen which means a task to have some
requirements for your app icon in order
for it to look good so the first thing
we need to do is that your app icon
should visually match the other app
icons around it so there are some visual
standards that it should match like
formats sizes another thing is to create
it create a responsive icon that can
work on any sizes because you remember
your PWA will be accessed throughout so
many different devices and sizes and
platforms so the best thing to do this
best thing the best way to design a
responsive icon is to make it as simple
as possible so your app icon should be
very unique shape that is very simple
with no complicated vectors and in no
words no characters and it should look
good on also on all sizes because your
icon will be on the splash screen or the
app install banner on the fast picture
participation banners so make sure to
test all these also make sure your app
icon looks good on all platforms so as I
said there's there are many formats for
each icon on different devices different
platforms for example on iOS the icons
can't be transparent they require a
background colors and if you do it as a
circle this will happen to have some
background bordered black border so it
needs to be a solid square there are
lots of other formats that should be
considered and the best way to see all
these is to use a generator I create
favicon generator net this is where you
can see all of the variations in one go
and it lets you make a drunk adjustments
for each platform then after you're done
it generates a manifest adjacent for you
so this is a nice and quick way to
design your items
another way to brand our app is to use
the team color so the team color gives
the brand and uniqueness for our PWA
and that's what it's what makes search
more like a native app so there are two
types of skin colors the first one is
the browser theme colors
this is the pbteen color that you see
when you open it from a browser so you
could use the primary or accent color
whatever color that works with your app
and this is how we do it so we add a
meta tag in the head we have a name team
color and the value in the content the
second one is the app theme color this
is the color that you could see when you
open the app via homescreen after you
add it to homescreen so as you can see
here the same color is on the staff
switcher as well in the header and the
status bar is is kind of automatically
colors from that color they just make a
darker and this is how we do so we add
the team color to the app manifest with
team color and the value another way to
meet the users expectations is to also
consider that there are also bigger
screens than mobile so of course when
designing the PWA
always start thinking about mobile first
but we also need to consider other sizes
others squeezed so we're doing it
evaluate which means it's 4 it should
work anywhere everywhere so why not just
also make it work on desktops and
laptops so this is like an extra step
that we should take and if the outside
website the PWA is the perfect example
of that they use the same exact design
of the mobile site and this made it a
bit bigger this is this is a great
example of EPW a so let's move on to the
next section how can we make progressive
web apps that are engaging so we need to
be responsive to the users input
much as possible which promotes feedback
and engagement so the first thing we
need to do is give give immediate visual
feedback whenever the user taps on the
screen on any where we should give
feedback to the user and this is what
makes it more like a native experience
as well so first consider the best and
worst tap areas this is really important
to consider first because after a lot of
research we found out that the top the
bottom left to top right is the best
area for tapping it's the most
comfortable way to talk on the screen at
the top left corner is the worst place
actually and Appin still doesn't get
that so we need to we need to understand
the best and that works tap areas and
especially for our own app so we need to
test and see what our audience wants so
always give immediate visual feedback
and try to respond to the user
immediately try to respond in under 100
milliseconds if you can so no matter
what the animation or transition speed
is try to start responding in under 100
milliseconds and also maintain a minimum
touch target size of 48 DP which is
density-independent pixels this is what
material design recommends this is to
ensure balanced information density and
usability and we know that small touch
targets tend to more frustration more
errors more problems the app install
banner is a great way to engage with
users and get them back to our app as
fast as possible so it has the ability
to have your users quickly and
seamlessly installed your app to their
home screen but only 11% actually
accepts this home screen of install
banner and the rest 52% ignore that so
we need to guide the users the users are
still not really familiar with
progressive web apps they're not
familiar that you could actually
and install your app to their home
screen so we need to guide them the best
way to do this is to add an app install
banners signifier like a button where
the user could click on this button and
we could guide them and tell them this
is where you could stop so this is what
Flipkart does they say when you tap on
that they say you could tap here in
order to add us to the home screen make
sure to set this on all browsers because
the overflow menu position could differ
on the browser what you can also do is
that after the user adds our app to the
home screen we could also remove that
button so in order to make it more
subtle so we could do that by hiding
this button one standalone so we add a
media query this playmode standalone and
we display:none
the button
another way also to tackle this problem
is to delay the app install banner until
the user engages with your app so we
know that we can not control this app
install banner yet but we can delay it
so this is a nice way to do it we just
delay it until after the user for
example here buy something from Flipkart
so it's more subtle and less annoying
and as I read in Google i/o conference
soon we'll be able to add to control
this app install banner so that's good
news notification push notifications are
great way to also engage with users and
even if the app is closed due to service
workers but it's a tricky way to have a
good push notification so first try not
to break the user's experience with a
push notification if you have something
like an update you do not have to send a
push notification to the user maybe you
could add like a snack bar in this
example just say that you could up you
could update this pw8 by tapping here so
this is way a way to notify the user
non-destructively there are some
guidelines for a people for push
notifications to be to be less annoying
so for example of this notification
should be personal to target the users
need it should also be timely so make
sure to work on the timer to send a push
notification and should be relevant so
try not to spam your users with push
notifications and it should be ex
actionable so you could add some actions
to it in order to in order to improve
engagement and it should work offline
and even when the app is closed so if
you want to also take it a bit further
you could give the user control over
their push notifications in this example
you could go into the sidebar and follow
the notifications on and off and this is
a nice way to make the user feel in
control
asking for permissions also can be a
hassle because it could be spammy so we
need to work on this so first don't ask
for permission or the first visit of a
website because nothing can be more
annoying than entering the website and
immediately asked me for my location for
example with that relevant context
without asking me anything before so it
can confuse users and maybe drive them
away from your website and also don't
use fake Android native banners I
noticed this on on Alibaba they have
this PWA now I noticed that this is this
is not a really native banner this is a
fake one this is the real one so they
show this and then they show them native
one which is confusing and if you're
familiar with the natives banners then
you'll notice this and doesn't really
really trust to the user so make sure
not to do that what you can do is ask
for permission when it's relevant so in
this example it's not what after you go
to use my camera then they will ask you
the permission to use your camera so
it's relevant it makes sense and it's
respectful when you're doing a PWA
remember that your users will open your
app maybe from the home screen which
means URL bar is not there anymore which
means you should work on providing a
share button and is a way to share your
PWA luckily there is a new web share API
that is coming soon to the web and what
is the what it does is that when you tap
on the share button it opens the native
sticker of a share so then the user will
choose from their native apps over to
share this PWA but this is coming soon
so what we can do meanwhile is implement
a share button but that lets you copy
the URL to the clipboard or also to
share from social media so this is a
nice way to give the ability to the
users to share your PWA
since we're talking about engagement
interaction I'd like to note that the
burger menu that sure you might be using
might be hurting your user experience so
here's why the burger menu may look
cleaner because you're hiding stuff
inside it but it has lower
discoverability because the users have
first the users might not notice at the
first time they have to talk first in
order for them to see the next section
it's less efficient because of that
extra top and the back button for iOS
will be reserved for the menu so this
has the clash with platform aggregation
of course we could move the burger menu
and add the back button but that's not
really a good solution so instead here
are some alternatives we could use tabs
tabs are now a design pattern in iOS and
Android so we could use that either on
the bottom or on the top and this tab
could also they have labels or they
could be just items depends on how
uncommon or common your icons are of
course some of you might be saying what
if I have more than five sections what
happens then so we could use a table
with a more option so this is a better
alternative for a burger menu because
it's right there the user would just see
the options in front of them and just
stop on one so it's more efficient so
thigh resized aside most important
sections and put them out there and
everything else flows inside more the
less important this tabs could also be a
scrollable tabs like Google's in the
categories now at the end of the day a
burger menu might make sense for certain
scenarios in uber everything is provided
on the home screen on the main screen so
we barely goes into that variant menu
unless we want some secondary options
like the history or settings so this is
a great example of using a burger menu
it makes sense
so let's move on to the most important
part progressive web apps should be
resilient to the load instantly performs
fast and could be connectivity
independence so first your apps should
feel local because 53 53 percent of
mobile users abandoned the site that
takes longer than three seconds to load
because users are impatient and
distracted from everywhere everything
around them so we need to work on a very
fast
first load let's take a look at this
example the normal scenario when you
open a web site on mobile this is what
happens you wait a bit you wait on a
wide screen
wait a little more and then everything
loads at the same time so this is normal
the progressive way is to immediately
start seeing components after component
and the loader and then the dynamic
component loads at the end so this
progressive way of loading reduces the
users uncertainty and reduces the
perception of time because you will see
that the website loaded fact actually
movie at the end the same time but just
progressively so the best way to do this
is to use the app shell model so the
action is the minimum HTML CSS and
JavaScript that powers the user
interface and here are some examples of
an actual this is Twitter lights app
shell as you can see it's very basic it
has the navbar some links it's a Google
inbox app shell and I'm showing you this
to tell you that the app shell works
everywhere is not just a mobile pattern
it should work on all sides and this is
out web action in action as we can see
so let's see what are the main
components of an action first we have a
navbar we have the tab bar or if using a
burger menu you have the sidebar
you have a background-color the loader
and if you have a main action that you
could add it here in the actual so
another way to work on a very fast load
first load is to inline some of our SVG
icons so first as a recommendation if
you have iTunes on your website then use
SVG icons rather than PNG because it's
very very small and if you want to also
take it a bit further you could end line
some of these SVG items three them a
good example in line only as SVG icons
above the fold so when you have icons
above the fold on the first first main
screen that the user sees then in line
those icons because those icons are the
most important items that the user
should see now if you online all the
icons on your website then your HTML
file will be huge which defeats the
purpose so that's why I've only aligned
the most important ones fonts are one of
the most common reasons of a slow load
over slow first loads so also we need to
work on these so what we can do is
remember that what fonts are heavy but
device fonts are weightless so if you
use device fonts on your PWA they will
feel more like home in the while they're
using the PWA so if it's wicked spell to
match the operating system it's a nice
way to show to first have a faster load
and to make it more feel like home so
what if there's a way to use robot on on
or on android and san francisco on is
and want to font on a 1 2 etc so we can
do this actually we could add all the
funds of the device as possible as fall
backs
and here let's say the user is using an
Android what happens is that the browser
reads Roboto and ignores everything else
so it's completely weightless and here's
the the relevant spawns for each
platform or device so the Apple system
is the San Francisco font for Safari
blank snakes blink Mac system font is
the equivalent to San Francisco for
Chrome and this goes on so this is a
nice way to use fonts you completely
weightless way and this is what we get
medium does this medium uses the Vice
fonts like the same way I showed you
and they also use the custom fonts in
other areas so in this example on iOS
the same font a San Francisco on iOS and
it's Roboto on Android now if you want
to use custom or web fonts you could
preload these phones because we know
that web fonts are heavy and they might
push away the load of your website so in
normal scenarios this is what happens
the index dot HTML starts loading CSS
files the SPSS file loads and then after
the SS CSS files completely completely
loads then the fonts start loading so
what we can do is preload these custom
fonts add a like link rel preload with
the font as a trap I mentioned that is
as front and also be more specific type
font both to and make sure to add the
cross origin because this is to avoid
double requests and this is what we get
the fonts will simultaneously load with
the CSS file so this avoids the flash of
unstyled content and avoids blocking the
page rendering
Devine it for the offline experience is
one of the most important parts of the
PWS and not just if it's offline but
also this if it has a low internet
connectivity and you might think that
there are not a lot of factors for a bad
internet connection maybe because you
live in here or maybe around Europe but
I live in Lebanon and Lebanon has one
megabyte per second speed and we have a
lot of problems in Internet and not just
us but also a lot of other countries so
we need to consider that there are some
factors of a bad network connection it
could be poor coverage of a provider and
there are lots of scenarios for that it
would have extreme weather conditions if
it's the lot of rain a lot of thunder
this could affect the internet
connection it could be power outages
whenever the power is off internet is
offline as well and if we could be also
travelling into bed zones and that could
happen anywhere when you go into the
metro sometimes the internet is offline
so your goal is to provide a good
experience that lessens the impact of
changes in this connectivity so here are
some tips when the app is offline don't
make the users experience this examples
you can see is going into products we
click on a product and boom it gives us
the dinosaur you are offline so we don't
want to bring break the users experience
like this so what we can do is first
clearly inform the user when it changes
state occurs and try to do that as soon
as possible and not only that but also
inform the user what actions they could
do so here you seem to have a bad
network connection but don't worry your
messages will be sent where the network
is restored so be transparent with the
user and thousand and when the app is
back online some apps might require also
updating like the weather for example
you can't have old data on a weather app
it has to be updated so that's why here
it makes sense to use auto updating and
how you deal with informing the user
that the app is back online
will depend on your app another example
is to inform the user a bit in the word
content with a factory-fresh button when
you're reading an article on a blog or
news website it's really horrible if you
auto update the page and you lose where
you were leading so this is where it
makes sense to use it back to refresh
button provide an offline experience by
default in this example we show that
user that the Internet is offline but
what you can do is you can access these
two categories and everything else are
not really accessible by buying it's a
cross line so it's also a nice way to
tell the user that you could access some
sections and our app and if your app
doesn't require much data then you could
catch these data by default and try to
make the experience as stable as
possible and if your data is heavy then
provide a data saver mode the perfect
example is Twitter Lite they have this
data saver mode that when you thousan it
on as you can see the videos and
pictures are blurred out and they're
only accessible when you tap on them and
this vid uses the data usage by up to
70% and that's great you could also give
the user control to download for offline
uses in websites like videos it's really
great if we could give the user ability
to download offline some specific
content like video this is an example
from the fire glass art and inform the
user when the app is ready for offline
consumption so here in Google i/o we say
cache incomplete future visits will work
offline
make sure the language you're using can
fit your audience so for example this
sentence makes sense
but service worker installed
successfully is not really a good
sentence so make sure to work on that
you could also give an offline mode to
your theme so we talked about the team
color it's great that you could add an
offline theme color so in this example
flip card everything blue turns to gray
when it's offline so it's a beautiful
way to show the user that is offline
with only color so an app that lessens
the impact of the network failure will
feel magical to the user so now I'm
going to talk about some other design
considerations to keep in mind the first
is we tend to forget that or skip that
because it's not really important but we
have to design for iOS for Mark's so I
asked doesn't fully support progressive
web app because they don't support the
service workers push notifications
insulation homescreen and does not
support - invitations so what we can do
first is as a launch I can stifle so
since iOS ignores this manifested Jason
we need to add a launch title as a
fallback and by default IFC's the title
tag in the header in the head another
problem we have is the app icon the app
icon on iOS is a screenshot I don't know
why so what we need to do is have a
fallback for this so we add this we
specify a web app icon like this a link
well after that I can with icon we can
also hide Safari your I components by
adding this Apple mobile web app capable
meta tag and this is a very dangerous
and powerful meta tag here's why first
is doesn't have a hardware back button
we know that which means if you enter a
website and doesn't it doesn't have a
back button you're stuck there forever
so another problem is some links might
open in a browser in atwa if you open a
PWA from the home screen and it's app on
a product in some scenarios it will open
the browser Safari and this is not a
really good experience so here's the
first solution we could add back
navigations everywhere on all pages and
we use location that it's Jeff instead
of the a for internal navigation and
this is what avoids opening in a browser
open the links and browser the other
solution is to just avoid the web app
capable meta tags and the perfect
example is Twitter they don't have this
robot capable meta tag when you open it
from the home screen it opens the
browser and this this is okay for now
until Apple fixes it you could keep the
icon and title as meta tags and just
remove the web app capable meta tag for
now it avoids the UX problems that you
might counter if you want to use web app
capable then you could also make it a
bit more that can native app so you
could change the status bar appearance
so you could do that by Apple mobile
will have status bar style and this is
the default color it's white we have
another one which is black and the third
one is black translucent what this does
is that it floats on top of the full
screen content instead of pushing it
down so we need to design for that we
need to either push our content
accordingly or make our navbar bigger so
despite the fact that is doesn't yet
support progressive web apps there are
lots of lots of brands and companies
that have a lot of great improvements in
iOS
for example Aliexpress on 82% increase
in iOS conversions and The Washington
Post has seen any of five times increase
in user engagement on iOS and I think
that's due to the best practices for
performance a faster load and a smoother
experience overall and the Washington
Post has also a combination of the PWA
and amp which allowed to offer a
game-changing
and this is the difference between a
current mobile web and their instant
mobile web so another thing to consider
is to design for accessibility and
low-end devices this might be a
challenge and we might skip that usually
but remember that 49 million people
suffer from accessibility and disability
problems like mobility hearing and
eyesight and since we're doing a PWA
that works everywhere why not make it
work with everyone so it might be a
challenge but if you design inclusively
you design for everyone so be aware of
global accessibility of color blind
people low-end devices expensive data
and some countries so what we can do is
be globally relevant using icons and
friendly English language so use simple
global English language that can work
for all people or energies and educated
people and be culturally relevant to use
fewer words more icons in order to be
more visible also consider high data
cost and low end phones so we could do
we could solve this by reducing our app
size which we already do in a PWA and
consider the small screen sizes as well
you could also minimize the battery
usage and let them know about beta calls
so when when they downloading something
for offline use for example show them
the the megabyte size of this thing that
they're downloading and also remember
that your PWA is going to be used on a
mobile phone which means it might be
that it's not going to be used on an
outdoor use so make sure to have
sufficient contrast for that and also
consider that some users would have will
have low vision which means also you
need to have more contrast you could
also use some colorblind simulation
filters and try not rely on color alone
you could see the device sizes sorry the
colors are material that io / color so
the last thought that I want to leave
you with is should I design separately
for iOS and Android most progressive web
apps design one one app that works
everywhere but some companies and some
brands like Barcelona City app they
tweak their design for one for Android
and another for iOS so it really depends
on your requirements on your needs and
apps and audience
so the takeaway of this box would be
first to take inspiration from native
apps so forget the web like experience
and design for an app like experience
also best on the crappiest device you
could find with remote debugging and
make sure your app works good everywhere
and that slight checklist just like this
one for your pwace in order to create
truly amazing experiences on the web if
you wanna know more about progressive
web apps design and user experience the
best place to find all these is on
Google web fundamentals
so I hope you enjoy the talk make sure
to follow me on Twitter because I'm
going to be tweeting the slides later on
and I'd love to answer your questions if
you have any thank you